salut les épicurieuses et les epicurieux
pour ce quatrième numéro de la classe
grandeur nature je vous emmène en
Ardèche
programme de cette excursion la descente
des Gorges de l'Ardèche en canoë
l'exploration d'une grotte unique nous
pénétrerons également dans un château
fort pour pratiquer l'esprit médiéval et
nous apprendrons à faire du feu comme le
faisait les hommes préhistoriques allez
c'est parti
et c'est parti
quand on évoque le sujet des canyons
inévitablement on pense à ceux des
États-Unis et bien c'est oublier qu'il y
en a également en France dans les gorges
de l'Ardèche des falaises de calcaire
qui s'élèvent à 300 mètres de hauteur
c'est vertigineux depuis 1980 c'est
gorge constitue une réserve naturelle
qui héberge une faune et une flore
exceptionnelle les Aigles de Bonelli par
exemple adore ces parois ils viennent
nicher dans les cavités et puis avec un
peu de chance on peut aussi croiser des
castors troglodytes on les appelle ainsi
parce qu'ils vivent dans des grottes qui
sont creusées dans les berges on ne voit
pas l'entrée parce qu'elle est inondée
mais ça les castors sont riches
ouh là je crois qu'il y a un rapide là
un rapide c'est quand la rivière se
rétrécit le courant accélère ou là-bas
je vous avais promis un joli paysage un
joli spectacle et bien il est devant moi
le Pont d'Arc cet arche fait 54 mètres
de hauteur et 60 dollars elle est
parfaitement naturel il n'y a eu aucun
coup de pioche ici il s'est creusé avec
le temps pour comprendre il suffit de
prendre un peu de hauteur et de faire un
grand bon dans le passé il y a 124000
ans la rivière dessinait à méandre à
cause de la force centrifuge le courant
de la rivière est beaucoup plus fort à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur du virage
l'eau rabonne donc davantage les berges
extérieurs où se trouvent les falaises à
force de travail l'eau a fini par percer
la falaise en creusant une arche pour
emprunter un chemin plus direct
elle a laissé derrière elle un méandre
sans eau ce que l'on appelle un bras
mort pour le moment cet arche est unique
mais à l'avenir il pourrait y en avoir
d'autres regardez bien le méandre à mes
pieds à l'endroit où il se resserre la
rivière continue de creuser de chaque
côté et bien un jour ou l'autre elle
pourrait finir par creuser une nouvelle
arche et prendre un raccourci mais bon
on a un peu de temps devant nous
quelques centaines de milliers d'années
en attendant nous allons poursuivre
notre classe grandeur nature après les
gorges je vous invite à descendre dans
les entrailles de l'Ardèche c'est très
profond suivez-moi il y a 250 marches
pour descendre jusqu'à la grotte
énorme cette salle mesure
120 mètres de long 80 mètres de large 30
mètres de hauteur la taille d'une
cathédrale d'ailleurs ça résonne comme
dans une cathédrale
cette grotte est qualifiée d'Aven parce
qu'à l'origine on y accédait par un
puits qui se trouve juste au-dessus de
ma tête et quand on descend dans une
grotte par un puits et bien c'est un
Avène d'ailleurs le mannequin qui est
suspendu à la plomb du puits illustre
cette voix d'accès c'est par ici qui est
descendu Robert de Joly en 1935 le
découvreur de la grotte on doit dire
l'inventeur
c'est vraiment grandiose
et dire qu'on visite qu'un dixième de la
grotte le reste est à la disposition des
spéléologues et des scientifiques
dans la veine d'Orgnac on déambule dans
une forêt de concrétion des stalactites
et des stalagmites il en pousse de
partout d'ailleurs il existe un moyen de
mnémotechnique pour ne pas les confondre
la stalactite avec un T donc du plafond
et la stalagmite avec un M monte vers le
plafond et quand les deux se rejoignent
elles forment une colonne comme derrière
moi
et là nous sommes devant ce que l'on
appelle un buffet d'orgue
lorsque des stalagmites rejoignent des
stalactites elles forment un rideau
calcaire alors quand on voit toutes ces
concrétions on se demande comment elle
se sont formées et bien tout commence
au-dessus de nos têtes sur le plancher
des vaches avec lapins quand elle
ressort à l'air libre au plafond de la
grotte l'eau retenue dans la goutte
s'évapore légèrement une petite partie
du calcaire jusque là dissout à
l'intérieur se dépose sur la stalactite
la concrétion se développe vers le bas
pour les stalagmites c'est la même chose
quand la goutte d'eau tombe du plafond
elle emporte avec elle un peu de
calcaire dissout qui va se déposer sur
la stalagmite alors ce phénomène prend
du temps on estime ici que les
concrétions calcaires grandissent en
moyenne de quelques millimètres par an
vous avez vu derrière moi c'est la tour
de Pise enfin c'est ainsi qu'on a
baptisé cette stalagmite vous devinez
pourquoi
parce qu'elle penche comme la tour de
Pise on estime que sa formation a
commencé il y a 450 000 ans si elle
pouvait parler elle en aurait des
histoires à raconter tiens à propos
d'histoire suivez-moi
l'aventure humaine en Ardèche a commencé
très tôt dès la préhistoire alors quand
on parle de préhistoire en Ardèche on
pense tout de suite à la grotte Chauvet
et à ses peintures rupestres qui se
trouvent d'ailleurs tout près d'ici et
qui lors d'une classe découverte mérite
une étape mais si vous voulez en savoir
davantage sur cette période il y a un
endroit incontournable
c'est écrit au-dessus de ma tête bonjour
on a souvent une image
erronée de nos ancêtres préhistoriques
tout de suite on pense à l'homme des
cavernes des individus couverts de poils
l'armée d'une massue et vivant au fond
des grottes et bien c'est totalement
faux même si nos ancêtres ont exploré
des grottes jusqu'au fond il ne s'y
installer pas une grotte c'est trop
sombre et trop humide nos ancêtres
vivaient à l'air libre en plein jour
comme ici sous des abris sous roche ou
bien dans des campements le long des
rivières ou dans la plaine et puis
ils étaient nomades
il se déplaçait au fil des saisons et en
fonction de leurs besoins cette cité de
la préhistoire n'est pas un musée comme
les autres d'abord c'est un centre de
recherche à deux pas d'ici il y a deux
chantiers de fouilles et puis c'est
aussi un endroit où l'on peut s'initier
apprendre à vivre comme nos ancêtres
préhistoriques à prendre à faire du feu
par exemple oups je vais louper ma leçon
alors comment fait-on du feu si on n'a
pas d'allumettes comment faisait nos
ancêtres préhistoriques comme ils
étaient très malins ils ont inventé
n'ont pas eu de mes deux méthodes il y
en a une on va taper des cailloux par
percussion et il y en a une on va
frotter des morceaux de bois c'est la
méthode par friction bon à ton avis
quelle pierre il faut pour faire du feu
je sais que beaucoup de gens pensent du
silex mais c'est pas ça c'est le piège
il nous faut une pierre bien
particulière ça s'appelle de la marque
acide ou de la pyrite c'est du fer avec
du soufre c'est parce qu'il y a du
soufre qu'on va pouvoir le la faire
brûler le principe c'est si tu tapes
avec une pierre plus dure tu vas
arracher des petits grains de fer et de
soufre qui composent la pierre en
tombant le source en flamme et ça fait
des étincelles super chaudes mais sur
quoi va-t-on faire tomber ces étincelles
pour que ça fasse de la braise il nous
faut l'amadouvier tu as cette partie là
un petit peu orange marron clair c'est
la chair du champignon ça s'appelle de
l'amadou alors moi j'en ai gratté je
vais faire tomber mes étincelles dessus
le combustible
et la chaleur les étincelles
on a la braise on va faire un petit feu
c'est parti si tu disais tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait un combustible mais aussi
du comburant pour faire du feu de l'air
donc moi je vais rajouter de l'air j'ai
soufflé dessus
contrairement aux apparences tu ne m'as
pas enfumé donc ça c'est la première
méthode la méthode par percussion la
seconde c'est même toi qui va le faire
là il y a pas d'étincelle la chaleur de
départ on l'a en frottant on va faire
tourner une baguette sur une planche le
principe il est très simple je vais
mettre au bord d'une petite cheminée et
en faisant ça toute la sciure de bois va
tomber dans la cheminée et comme j'ai
tourné très vite ça va créer un courant
d'air et si j'ai deux l'air qui passe
dans un tas de sciure chaud là ça va
faire une braise on va céder d'un archet
et là la difficulté c'est de garder la
baguette droite
allez on donne tout allez allez allez
stop
super c'est bon
petite merde on va réussir à la sauver
super
et voilà
j'ai fait du feu excellent c'est la
première fois que je fais du feu comme
ça c'est génial bien merci beaucoup
Maylis pour cette jolie leçon ce joli et
partage de savoir-faire merci d'être
venu jusqu'ici de plonger dans notre
préhistoire lointaine et j'espère que je
saurais faire sans toi je n'en doute pas
la préhistoire n'est pas la seule à
avoir laissé son empreinte en Ardèche
l'histoire et en particulier la période
médiévale a aussi laissé des traces dans
la région bien visibles cette fois entre
le 10ème et le 12e siècle la région qui
s'appelle alors le Vivarais s'enrichit
des forteresses restent alors un peu
partout comme le château de Montréal où
l'on m'attend pour une leçon d'escrime
médiévale tout cela dans le cadre d'une
classe découverte
alors dans la vie civile vous êtes guif
Fabre oui mais dès que vous franchissez
cette porte vous êtes qui dès que je
suis en costume je franchis cette porte
ou une autre je suis Arnaud de Rochegude
chevalier de Balazuc capitaine de route
des corbeaux de Taranis
je fais le serment cette protéger et de
devenir un aide chaque fois que ce sera
nécessaire debout vassal une guide du
rubrique en tant que vassal peut
apporter ceci chaque fois que je crierai
vassal j'ai soif tu es un homme apporter
un boire va toute la classe découverte
vous allez accompagner les enfants sous
ce nom oui ils ne seront jamais que je
m'appelle Guy il ne me verront jamais
habillé comme un homme du 21e siècle
c'est le principe de l'immersion totale
la salle j'ai soif
manque de chance pour vous Vincelle je
n'ai jamais pas soif les enfants
apprennent plein de choses combien de
temps dure ce séjour dure une semaine
comme on les a fait beaucoup travailler
pendant toute la semaine le vendredi
matin c'est grand jeu je leur fais
reconstituer la bataille d'astings alors
que la moitié des élèves vont faire les
Saxons les autres les Normands et après
on termine sur une troisième manche ou
là je prends mes armes réelles je vais
en tenue de bataille je leur dis
maintenant vous êtes tous des Saxons et
à moi tout seul je suis le Normand et je
vous charge un véritable arme et en
général je termine avec le bouclier sur
la tête et 25 élèves qui me tapent
dessus mais vous leur donnez quand même
quelques rudiments pour manier les armes
ils ont deux journées d'escrime il y en
a une cet après-midi à laquelle je peux
participer
au l'honneur le droit et la justice je
te confère l'ordre de chevalerie un
homme c'est à Genouillé
le chevalier se relève que ceci soit le
dernier coup que tu reçois un homme
libre sans jamais devoir le rendre
vachevalier je n'ai jamais manié l'épée
de ma vie mais pourquoi pas ce sera une
première alors c'est c'est mon maître
d'armes qui vous apprendra mais c'est
remerka de Macross un chevalier de
Calédonie
j'espère que cette journée en Ardèche
vous a plu qu'elle aura donné des idées
à toutes celles et ceux qui organisent
des classes découvertes je vous invite
d'ailleurs à regarder les autres numéros
de la classe grandeur nature bonne fin
de weekend excellente semaine à toutes
et à tous et on se retrouve dimanche
prochain pour de nouvelles découvertes
épicurieuses
[Applaudissements]